la diabetes tipo 2 es una afección en la
cual el nivel de azúcar en la sangre es
muy elevado después de que usted come
alimentos que contienen carbohidratos
los productos químicos en el intestino
delgado los descomponen en moléculas de
azúcar simple llamadas glucosa
luego las células que recubren el
intestino delgado absorben la glucosa
la cual pasa al torrente sanguíneo
cuando la sangre llega al páncreas las
células beta del páncreas detectan el
incremento de los niveles de glucosa las
células beta liberan insulina en el
torrente sanguíneo para reducir los
niveles de glucosa
a medida que la sangre circula a través
del cuerpo la insulina y la glucosa
salen del torrente sanguíneo hacia los
tejidos para alcanzar las células del
cuerpo la mayoría de las células del
cuerpo tienen ciertos receptores en su
superficie que se unen a la insulina
circulante
la insulina actúa como la llave de una
cerradura para abrir la célula de tal
manera que la glucosa circulante pueda
ingresar a dicha célula
ahora las células pueden aprovechar la
glucosa y producir la energía que
necesitan para funcionar correctamente
si usted sufre de diabetes tipo 2
entonces el páncreas no produce
suficiente insulina
las células del cuerpo resisten sus
efectos y ocurren ambas cosas
si tiene resistencia a la insulina su
insulina no puede abrir las células para
dejar ingresar a la glucosa porque las
cerraduras llamados receptores son
anormales o están ausentes
como consecuencia la glucosa queda sin
acceso a las células
por consiguiente la glucosa se acumula
en el torrente sanguíneo durante una
afección llamada
hiperglucemia
para compensar la hiperglucemia el
páncreas produce más y más insulina
las células beta trabajan en exceso e
intentan mantener la demanda pero poco a
poco van perdiendo la capacidad de
producir insulina suficiente
debido a la hiperglucemia y la falta de
insulina podría experimentar los
siguientes síntomas clásicos de la
diabetes
apetito y sed excesivos
aumento en el volumen de orina y pérdida
de peso inexplicable
los síntomas de la diabetes tipo 2 que
pueden presentarse con el paso del
tiempo son cansancio
infecciones recurrentes cambios en la
visión picazón y sensación de hormigueo
o cosquilleo en la piel
y las complicaciones que ponen en riesgo
la vida producidas por la diabetes tipo
2 incluyen cetoacidosis diabética
síndrome hiperglucemia hiperosmolar no
se tóxico e hipoglucemia
si no recibe tratamiento para la
hiperglucemia puede ocurrir una
cetoacidosis diabética
debido a que ya no tiene insulina
suficientes circulando en la sangre las
células no reciben la glucosa que
necesitan para producir energía como
consecuencia la sangre recurre a las
grasas y proteínas como fuente de
energía alternativa
durante el proceso de descomposición de
grasas ciertos subproductos conocidos
como cuerpos cetónicos se acumulan en la
sangre dando lugar a una afección
llamada cetosis
si los cuerpos se tóxicos se acumulan a
niveles peligrosamente altos en el
torrente sanguíneo puede desarrollarse
tu acidosis diabética o cds
que puede derivar en un coma y la muerte
otra complicación que se deriva de no
tratar la hiperglucemia se llama
síndrome hiperglucemia hiperosmolar no
se tóxico o s
nc a medida que la deficiencia de
insulina continúa su nivel de glucosa en
sangre aumenta como respuesta los
riñones filtran el exceso de glucosa
fuera de la sangre en la orina junto con
grandes cantidades de agua
a menos que consuma grandes cantidades
de agua los riñones no podrán mantener
la demanda de eliminar la glucosa del
torrente sanguíneo
y de diluir la en la orina en forma
suficiente como consecuencia la sangre
estará mucho más concentrada de lo
normal una afección llamada hiperosmolar
y that la hiper osmolaridad arrastra el
agua de los tejidos corporales al
torrente sanguíneo y ocasiona una grave
deshidratación que puede derivar en
síndrome hiperglucemia hiperosmolar no
se tóxico pueden aparecer síntomas
neurológicos como convulsiones y coma
si ingiere una dosis excesiva de
medicamento para la diabetes puede
experimentar una complicación aguda
llamada hipoglucemia o choque insulínico
el exceso de insulina o medicamento
hiperglucemia oral hace que haya
demasiada glucosa en las células lo cual
deja una cantidad insuficiente en el
torrente sanguíneo
algunos órganos como el cerebro
necesitan un suministro de energía
constante para funcionar en forma
adecuada debido a que la fuente de
energía del cerebro es la glucosa este
es el primer órgano afectado por los
bajos niveles de glucosa
cuando las células del cerebro llamadas
neuronas tienen gran necesidad de
glucosa empiezan a funcionar mal lo que
causa síntomas como nerviosismo
temblores y confusión si el nivel de
glucosa sigue bajando
la actividad eléctrica de las neuronas
disminuye en forma significativa y tiene
como consecuencia convulsiones o coma
diabético
con el tiempo la diabetes tipo 2 crónica
mal controlada puede causar daño
degenerativo en el tejido que tiene como
consecuencia
complicaciones a largo plazo como
aterosclerosis ceguera
neuropatía e insuficiencia renal
a fin de evitar las complicaciones de la
diabetes tipo 2 puede tomar medidas para
mantener el nivel de glucosa dentro del
intervalo normal mediante el uso de una
combinación de control de la glucosa en
sangre una dieta sana
ejercicio regular y medicamentos según
sea necesario
deberá controlar el nivel de glucosa en
sangre en forma frecuente con un
glucómetro para esto debe pincharse el
dedo con una aguja pequeña llamada
lanceta y colocar una gota de sangre en
la tira del glucómetro
considerando su nivel de azúcar en
sangre quizá deba ajustar sus comidas la
actividad física o la dosis de los
medicamentos
llevar una dieta saludable ayudará a
disminuir su nivel de glucosa cuando
consuma abundantes frutas verduras y
granos enteros realice sus comidas y
refrigerios a la misma hora todos los
días consume una cantidad balanceada de
carbohidratos proteínas y grasas y
minimiza su ingesta de alimentos con
alto contenido de azúcar
la realización de ejercicios en forma
regular incluso solo 30 minutos al día
disminuirá su nivel de glucosa en sangre
disminuirá su resistencia a la insulina
y podría derivar en la pérdida de peso
quizá necesite uno o más medicamentos
para la diabetes para ayudar a disminuir
su glucosa en sangre
algunos de estos medicamentos aumentan
la producción de insulina en el páncreas
otros disminuyen la resistencia a la
insulina en los músculos esqueléticos
algunos tratamientos aumentan la
sensibilidad a la insulina en
determinados tejidos
otros promueven una leve disminución de
la absorción de glucosa en el sistema
digestivo
si no es posible controlar la diabetes
tipo 2 mediante dieta ejercicios y
medicamentos orales su médico podría
recetar la insulina y capacitarlo para
aplicarse inyecciones subcutáneas
al tratar y controlar su nivel de
glucosa en sangre puede evitar la
ocurrencia de complicaciones de la
diabetes tipo 2